hey ram rambling rabbit rabbit can i
speak to you in vc4 for a second sure
yo rambu we could buy we could buy this hotel
we put our diamonds together we buy this place
i don't know you think i kind of like i don't
i i mean okay it's a it's a good building right
it's big and oh yeah no but what we do is
we buy it and then we rent it out to jack
we we buy our competition we buy it
and then rent it out to jack yeah
so we just we have the deeds but jack is there
um i don't know i don't know if that's
legal if i'm entirely honest it's minecraft
anything goes like okay no no what we could
do is no no what we could do no oh my god we
could buy it and get jack to turn into a casino
i don't know i don't know i mean doesn't doesn't
technically technically uh isn't it technically
tommy's always in college said that it was i
mean you said it yourself about logics not flawed
yeah but like it i don't think he has the ability
to like sell it should we ask him about it we
should we should go don't be like jack battlefield
how do two stacks of diamond blocks sound i'm not
going to give them two stacks of diamonds i'm not
going to give them my you're not going to use my
money why all i need is a small loan i mean i'm
not gonna give him all i hate is this no no no
no no no okay the thing is though right yeah the
thing is though if we if we were to own it right
yeah it's kind of it's kind of a it's kind of a
jerk move because we're renting we're stealing
it from a guy that like doesn't even he doesn't
even know that like jack has it oh yeah trey yeah
yeah yeah and then also we need we need
we need friendly competition i mean oh we
so we want to we want to kill him with yeah
let's go and kill him with kindness let's go
hey jack manifold we're here to kill you with
kindness no don't jack manifold it's not it's not
gonna happen oh wait what did you mean what did
you mean wait what do you mean no i meant i meant
i mean we just kind of just like let let things
happen here i mean when you when you think about
it when you think about it like there's already
fighting between like the two people that work
there oh there's only one person that works
here because the other one is in jail jack
manifold how much is this place for sale no
we're not selling it because it's my big hotel
okay yeah yeah see he wasn't i knew he wasn't
gonna sell you a room for five diamonds though
jack your room there's not even a pool there's
no games room there's no kitchen where's yours
it's on the roof show me your pool we we have
construction constructing it we're still under
construction yeah no i wouldn't stay there because
it's not even built mine is built jackman i mean
yours is built and no one's staying there yeah so
what does that say about boy hello okay skeppy and
bad boy hello who actually happened to have a
mansion there and also live 10 000 blocks away
yeah but they stay here they have rooms that's
why it says it on the doors uh i think you've just
been played i don't know could you be in just they
paid for it tobo it doesn't matter they pay okay
if they didn't pay wait oh wait okay how much is a
room five diamonds how long do i get the room for
just forever a week a week yeah you get it for a
week i'll have five rooms trust me trust me i'm
killing him with kindness five rooms please okay
sure which which rooms do you want one of them
there's more than five wait there's
more than five rooms you have to show
me specifically spend 25 diamonds for
that i want i want i want the top ones
okay let's come to the top top we'll get you
you'll get don't worry rambo it's an investment
we can use it you are not responsible with here
we can stake we can do a stakeout we can do a
stakeout we're doing a stakeout we're doing a
stakeout you're just so oh wait i forgot about
room 10. do you want room 10 this one will cost
you 15 diamonds though 15 diamonds for room 10
what's in room temperature the same as room nine
and room 11 yeah wait wait there's oh right okay
well never mind these three will cost you 15 each
uh no you've been up this high yet yeah you're not
you're not a very good employee wait you haven't
even been up this high in your own hotel i won
i won i won eight seven i won eight seven six and
five it's in the name i didn't realize it was this
big which ones do you want i want eight seven
six five and four all right fine uh all right
let me let me so you rename them all tubber room
one turbo room two tupperware room three tableau
which way are we counting sir downwards
so you want to start with one here
see this is what we do rambo we support locusts
we support local business this is our this is good
publicity i appreciate that gentlemen that's true
you know you know this business is not clearly
yeah it is it definitely is yeah what
do you mean it's struggling we just
sold five rooms yeah we have to support local
business yeah we have to support someone sold
five rooms to this dude i'm not
struggling at all this is that's
as most of our rooms are now sold you
only have given me four i need one more
yeah i know but i've only had this place for
two days i've just sold five rooms that's good
i'm not struggling at all but thank you for your
your money you know i think you've actually sold
seven yeah you've actually sold yeah well actually
those were already sold those already sold and i i
didn't do that i won't take credit where credit
we've got to support this small business rambu
this business is not small it's so
big like the name implies what is this
jack manifolds specifically so soite this is my
suite this is where i live this is my my bed how
much for this there might be a little there might
be a little bit of one because it's where i live
how much for this one okay you can't buy my one
jack how much for this one that's my wife you
this isn't even furnished you know what a
hundred diamonds if you want to live in my suite
please jack i want a refund please i don't want
my five rooms anymore no you don't get refunds we
don't do those well i guess i'll just have to take
him back no don't kill oh boy no check manifold
no jack mata phone refunds the policy says
strictly no refunds i love it when the hotel
manager runs away well i guess i guess we open
the entire hotel now he's gone around here
i'm gonna come back i guess we start redecorating
no you don't own it we take down the wall between
the kitchen and the river just not now i think
we're open for a more open concept i think we take
down the wall between the creatures living room
make it very much a closed concept i like it the
way it is yeah for a more open concept i say we
take down the wall between this room and this room
no no more okay no let's take down the outside
walls let's take down the outside rules yeah
see rambu this is my fan all along now we own this
place no stop it don't tell me to stop it stop it
cute right cute what do you mean ha
cute i'd say we need to rebrand this
hotel i think we need a rebrand so we can enjoy it
there we go i've rebranded it
it's mine you can't steal i will take
you to court tommo jack i am the lawyer
you will not stand a chance tomorrow i will
sue you for everything you own you're gonna
ask me to sue myself that's not gonna work i'm
also the judge did i mention i'm also the judge
tomorrow i'm going to sue you jack i'm above the
law tomorrow i'll win if i sue you you know what
i'm fighting we're doing this we're
going to court we're going to court
we're going to court this is a custody
battle rambo and it's going to be aggressive
though oh well that that seems to be a problem
for you to solve right now represent yourself
jack the court date's in two minutes
because i have to go and play chess soon
we can't do a we tubbo we can't do
court in two minutes i need we can
yeah i know i've got a date tomorrow but
you know jackie's going on a date tomorrow
uh on the dream smp in my restaurant i built yeah
yeah they're going on i have a restaurant no one
goes there but me on my date ah i don't know is
this serious just just not where would you would
you go on a date rambu why would you go on a date
ooh i think like we should go into my identity
marks are really fun amusement park oh that's
true i actually am terrified of roller coasters
exactly and that's what would make it fun
you are you're an evil evil man you are
exactly so are we are we still going
to court i'm going to court i'm going
to testify to myself against jack manifold
and win without him even showing up okay
this is how i do things where i come from
down in the law business yeah oh my god
yeah yeah oh man you know i was i was in court
on like the like the third day of me being here
jesus
yeah baby that's what i've been waiting
for that's what it's all about magic time
we're in the game
oh
welcome everyone to pogchamps 3 presented by grip
six i'm alexandra and i'm joined by honorary woman
grand master and previous pog champs participants
cutie cinderella cutie what does it feel like
being on the other side good they couldn't
get anyone to show up again so here i am guys
it's me no it's good to have you i saw your
commentary with robert and that seemed super
entertaining so i feel like chad is going to be
very pumped that you're here i think they like me
i think i dumb it down enough you know there's a
lot of smart people in chat but there's a lot of
dumb people in chat you know you know how to talk
to the people and that's the skill we're here for
that's what i'm here to reflect and i'm happy
to see you still have hair cutie i have four
days until i have to go bald i feel like i'm gonna
throw up my anxiety is through the roof and i'm so
excited to have a distraction for a little bit i'm
sorry yeah yeah yeah yeah no it's gonna be great
it's gonna be great well speaking of distractions
let's talk a little bit about the format today
it's going to be single elimination double round
robin which means that for the match today we are
going to have code miko and tubo playing two games
one is white one is black if it is a tie then they
are going to go into the tie breaks which is
five minutes zero second increment and they are
already in the consolation brackets so whoever
wins is gonna make it to the semifinals and the
loser unfortunately is gonna be eliminated cutie
last time you were here how far did you make it
uh i made it i think i only made it to
the first round of the consolation bracket
well well hey that's as far as one of the
participants today is going to make it so you're
very much in their same shoes any advice you
would have offered them i uh i just you know just
i think i see myself a lot in mikko uh miko and
i are really good friends but number one she
was like [ __ ] this um and then she was like
wait i actually care and she's been putting a
ton of hours in since then so i'm hoping i'm
hoping that i hope she at least gets a match
yeah there you go the game out of the
match i do think tubble will win but i hope
i hope miko gets a game i definitely echo that
she is the underdog but it's good to know that
she's been grinding off stream so she's had some
really strong starts and she actually definitely
has the potential to get at least one but let's
remind everybody part of the good pogchamps is
doing as well the community outreach so chess.com
is matching up to a hundred thousand dollars
of the viewers donations and these donations will
be given to the participants preferred non-profit
organizations you can see that depending on how
people place in the championship bracket or the
consolation bracket it's going to dictate how
much they can donate so this is pretty cool
cutie do you have any favorite charities
from the participants or maybe any you like
um well i'm excited for ludwig to get first place
and donate to no kid hungry uh big fan of that
so you know we know we're the bias at all no bias
zero bias i just love no kid hungry and i just
think they should get all the winning money so
well cutie you're not the only one cheering for
for ludwig world champion magnus carlson
also tweeted that he hopes ludwig wins so
you know at least you're in good company with
who you're rooting for yeah me and magnus have
been having watch parties um i bring the snacks he
brings the brains and it's been a good time yeah
when is he coming on eagle rejects i feel like
he'd be a great guest we will have him soon maybe
maybe uh i guess he is more fit for igor rejects
and housewives of twitch so we'll see what we
can do imagine casey and minx learning chess from
magnus someone has to make that happen that would
be the end of him he would be done well let's take
a look at the match today so as cutie mentioned
she is good friends with code miko code miko has
been training tubo has also been training a lot
of chess and he actually originally said that he
was motivated to play chess to beat his grandpa so
and he's beaten his grandpa two days in a row
now so regardless what happens i feel like tubble
already wanted his heart that's so cute what a
sweet boy it is it is actually very wholesome so
we're going to give him a shout out for that
and we also want to give a shout out to guayaqui
for helping make pog champs possible as
guayaqui celebrates 25 years of regenerative
yerba mate they're sharing cases to celebrate
span the guayaqui emote in chat for your chance
to win and we will be back with the match in
just a moment the regeneration of the planet
is integrated into our business model purchases
of guayaqui yerba mate support stewardship of
the south american atlantic rainforest and the
self-sufficiency of indigenous communities these
purchases advance a carbon-balanced renewable
energy economy and provide meaningful employment
for the formerly incarcerated sales also fuel
communities and activists driving the regenerative
movement meanwhile your enjoyment of yerba
mate reconnects you with the vitality of life
when we come to life we care about one another
and stand together to create a better future
spamming me to kill him i honestly i could not
resist it was peer pressure it was peer pressure
they peer pressured me into ruthlessly shooting
him to death oh my god that that poor man is just
trying to own this hotel i like this i think this
is a nice design i really do good we could own
this design it took me it took me like an hour
to come up with it while chat was yelling at me
they were yelling at me ugly and i'm like
please oh rambo there's a creeper and you
hopped in front of me are you okay oh
yeah i'm okay i really like wearing
dreams armor i'm literally wearing
all of dream's armor and belongings
these are the very same items
that he used to nearly murder me
it's quite nice hey i think it's time for me to
play chess oh okay is don't you have an exam now
uh not yet can you cheer me on from the
sidelines while we wait for the chat sure
i really would appreciate it if you guys would
stick in the stream i know chess isn't everyone's
strong suit if you would support me we'll be
doing predictions which are going to be fun
yeah okay game in four minutes yep ah i'd
appreciate it if you stuck around for the for
the ride i swear i'll make it interesting last
time we did some singing we did some dancing
when we were winning and the time before we did
some moping when we lost so i don't know yeah
i really don't of course streamer
people love oh topic of the hotel would
be like the runner-up to the employee just
oh my god i'll be here wait oh my god okay
i oh people are asking to be like runner
up for the be employee of the month
oh it's gonna be so not lovely it's going
to be awesome i'm going to collect a lot
more resources today and maybe see like how
we're going to build it yeah i'm excited wait
why would i search up chess.com does tubbo's
new secret channel brackets leak to come up
whatever whatever
my new secret channel has been
leaked how will i ever cope
how will you how will you cope with
that oh man how will i ever cope
this is truly awful look at you doing chess wow
look at me doing chess like a like a like a like
a twitch streamer yeah my my twitch streamer plays
chess my stream is five head i guess that much and
apollo fan for the um five gifted jesus christ
yeah chat for those of you that don't know why
i'm so tired me and rambo were talking on discord
until 10 a.m nearly 11. and yep i want to die
was there i don't think our
conversation was that bad no i'm
tired and now i have to use now i
have to use big brain to play chess
oh shoot yeah wait yeah no wait um i don't
um my streamer is married oh god oh god
oh my goodness time pipers yeah oh god my stream
would do board game it's not just a ball game
oh my god we should do a monopoly stream sorry
that just crossed my mind oh no okay yeah monopoly
was so much fun i played it i played it with
um i played it with um with uh dream bad and
sap nap and carl and it was so much fun because we
took it super seriously oh my god we like like it
was doing a monopoly stream let's do chat we hit
the sub goal today oh i'll do a monopoly stream
subscribe for the monopoly
stream and also the irf stream
oh wait why don't i have hold
up do you not have twitch prime
no i'm setting up here i'm pretty sure wait
i'm pretty sure that i'm pretty sure that i
gave for when jack was doing a subathon i gave
my prime to jack so i'm just here i'm bj minton
the founder of grip six when i was 14 my very
first job was a janitor at an elementary school
and i saved up my money and one of the first
things i bought was a wooden chessboard
from the mall i love chess chess is challenging
chess is thinking ahead it's planning it's problem
solving it's very similar in manufacturing
because in manufacturing it's nothing but
problems but problems are what stimulate your
brain problems are the things that actually push
you into creating new things new technology
better products things like that at grip6 we
make belts wallets and socks we guarantee them
for life and just like chest they'll be around
forever yesterday group 6 gave away a premium
chess set made specifically for the tournament
the winner was not tuckery gillery so
congratulations you guys can actually
win things if you chat and if you spam kappas
that's not going to help your chances so
make sure you're in the list as they're giving
away some belts and socks if you want your hands
on their amazing socks belts and wallets be
sure to use code pogchamps20 at go.chess.com
champs now let's get back to the action we
have one game today it's going to be well
one match code miko versus tubo uh cutie you've
been saying that code miko has been training
do you want to give a little bit more details
into that if you have any yeah she she finally
decided i think anybody who streams on twitch
doesn't like being a loser and was just sick of it
and so then she she spent hours like six hours the
other day just playing chess back to back to back
she's trying really really hard i don't i
i think i mean obviously i think tubbo is
definitely still the favor here but i don't know
i just want every it's so hard it's so hard when
you have to choose because you say the thing
about tubbo and it's grandpa i'm like i want to
win and then i'm like oh me going to win and i
don't know so it's hard but yeah absolutely i want
a good game i feel that is a little bit more fair
since both code miko and tubo have been training
they're both great creators and i actually see
that code miko is now over 400 last time she's
in the 300 range so we see some progress yeah
she's been grinding i think she still doesn't know
uh like any solid openings to my knowledge she
doesn't have any of those lines like really
memorized but it looks like she's working on
she's doing the copy technique here the coffee
technique that sounds much better than the actual
name so let's just go for that the petrov is now
the copy technique and i will say this is not
the best opening for beginners to play because
it includes a lot of theory and it's pretty
tactical is this something you tried before
um i well that's what so when i learned black
that is what levy told me levy told me just copy
what they're doing oh okay and so that is what
i told her actually yeah like at the beginning
when you're on black side it's just so it's
so hard to know so that's actually some five
head advice for cramming for a chess game it's
like the spark notes for it i appreciate that
and it's good to see tubbo vibing as well he's
always dancing every time he's playing his games
yeah that's what i've learned about good streamers
and why i can never be one is that they have so
much energy and i'm like on my 12th cup of coffee
like i can't dance still like i don't i don't get
it it's okay you bring all of like the uh humor
you know and the wit so that's important as well
yeah i guess maybe just bitterness i suppose just
a sprinkle of bitterness here and there is okay
speaking of being i don't know he's
not bitter but he's taking a long time
here he took almost one minute to make his
fifth move bishop b5 and this is a totally
okay move that being said code miko is going
to be able to develop pretty quickly here
oh okay and he's just trading off all of her
pieces uh knight takes c7 and now i guess tubble
can take the knight on d7 or he can retreat and
okay pushes d4 instead see miko's actually and
this is like small things that probably people
don't notice but mikko's actually doing so much
better than she ever has played because she's
making conscious thoughts like i'm going to take
that bishop with my knight instead of my queen
because i don't want to lose my queens like
this seems like a small step in chess but
this is big for mikko cause she's brand new
like she didn't know how the pieces moved so this
is still exciting absolutely and last time i saw
her game she was making most moves within like
two to ten seconds she was playing so quickly and
now she's actually slowed down a little bit and if
she can keep up that tempo i think that's her best
chance uh to go up against someone who's twice
her elo and for the record miko isn't feeling
well today so that's why her cam isn't on um
but she still showed up to play which is amazing
yeah you're right i was i was gonna just not
say anything and maybe people would think that's
her camera since she's a tuber anyway just
staring intensely at tumbo the entire time
oh man okay so tubbo is in check now and
he's going to have to defend the check
so he can either play bishop d2 or knight c3
why do you think he pushes his pawn instead of
developing his pieces here alex that
is a question that i definitely know um
you're the woman jim and you know what if you
stay with confidence we're gonna run with it
he did that because he he because he wanted to
alex and that's why you know what this is the kind
of expertise that is going to be refreshing chat
we don't get it all the time cutie just says it
like it is so it's perfect it's about time it's
exactly exactly um well now tubo is developing
so this is good and oh that is not a good move
you do not want to push your king side pawn so
she is attacking the bishop but even if he just
makes a normal move and retreats now she's going
to have a big target on her king side so i like
king side that's what i always say it is a naked
king side and uh you you don't want to be the
naked king do you ever remember reading that fable
no the one where the king um was given imaginary
clothes by somebody and everybody in the town was
too afraid to tell him so he was just walking
around naked until a kid in the village started
laughing i thought this was a famous story oh my
god emperor's new clothes emperor's new clothes
yeah i've never i've never i've never cutie's
like this is a weird story where did you have to
ask my dad about that one that's i was a disney
kid i don't know okay they didn't make a disney
movie about the naked king i don't know why no
you're right you're right if it's not a disney
movie then it's not even a real story so we're
not gonna count it but i'm glad to see that toppo
played bishop e3 and he's still fist-bumping he
still has so much energy he is young and it's
good that he has that energy now you know as you
as you reach our age you get a little bit more
i'm being told it was a disney
movie and now i'm embarrassed
yes it's okay you can add it to your watch list i
have a i'm i have an angry cat that i just have no
solution for him i have to let him out really
really quick i'm so sorry no worries no worries
uh go go let the cat out so code miko is sitting
here let's see she's a minute lower than tubbo
she's already pushed this pawn so she's weak
in her king side and in this situation i think
what she's going to struggle with is making a
plan so she already developed all of her pieces
what i would try to do if i were mikko is somehow
try to get my rooks into the game defend the pawn
on g5 because if we kick the knight out from
e4 and play something like queen d2 it might
end up being a target and the other question
is where is she gonna put her knight after a
move like f3 she can't go to c5 right away so she
actually doesn't have any safe squares and that
is why the evaluation just completely shifted here
because now if tubble plays f3 her pony is trapped
cutie do you think tubbo is gonna see f3 based
on what you've seen with his chest so far
i i think he's either gonna if he doesn't see f3
i think he's just gonna develop his other knight
um because when in doubt as a new chess
player it's like okay uh i don't know
what to do let me move this piece and you just
move whatever piece you haven't moved yet oh
and he he so he i don't think he's noticed that
the knight is trapped because what he just did
removed the um threat on e6 so now code miko
can retreat her night there so she actually has
a decent position and on top of that the e6 pawn
cannot be protected by another pawn so it's going
to be a pretty big weakness for him here okay
code miko's really bold she's just pushing all
over her paw she is going all the way down i think
she wants to trap that bishop yeah uh i i mean i i
respect i respect the hustle she's going for here
it is going to create long-term problems but you
never know what's going to happen this early i i
kind of like her her aggressive style do you feel
like it's going to pay off i think oh what did
we just miss oh he moved his bishop so yeah okay
i think i think in beginner's chess being
aggressive does pay off and maybe i'm crazy
but listen i play like a crazy person running
around just like shooting my gun in the air and
sometimes not life right cutie okay right yeah
chest chest chest oh man you know i just take
what i can take and i i go as hard and fast
as i can uh cutie you know what my first
impression of you was what it was a clip
of you before you were dating ludwig
saying how you had put bed bugs in your ex's bed
oh my god guys that is something that is something
yeah that was you know everything you hear on the
internet is true by the way yeah right not not all
it's not all content a hundred percent um i i i
don't know i was guessing it was for content and
regardless it's more fun if people never know
so i like them not to know yeah exactly exactly
tumble pushes g3 so both of them are really
pushing their king side pawns i love that
they're just playing with pawns yeah are you sure
you didn't give tubbo the copy advice as well
i think i think he's just he's doing the i don't
know what to do i'm gonna do what she's doing
oh okay so now tubbo could bring his queen into
the party defend the e6 pawn and put pressure on
g5 that's one idea i'm sure he's gonna see this
that night that b night scott he's got to bring
it into play soon as a new player that's all you
do you just scan and you're like what haven't i
touched yet somebody said something about touching
more pieces is that like how your brain works
that's how my brain works no every single time i'm
losing a lot my brain actually goes back to the
okay levy said to slow down donya said this
so-and-so said this i'm like this is stupid
you seem so enthusiastic about listening
to your coaches i hate it i hate listening
my coaches but then like i actually
win when i do and then i'm like mad
oh yeah you're like i guess they do know better
than me no i feel the same whenever my coaches are
hanging around and sometimes i i think i know
better and then i get really punished for it
but then i'm still stubborn i think
it's a a normal gaming thing to do
okay oh hubba was attacking on the wrong side
this is a pawn game and i'm living for it
yeah you know cutie your advice is
becoming even more accurate now i'd
love to see him develop his night because
i'm worried he's gonna forget to do it
yeah and his knight doesn't have a ton of options
right now code miko saw the threat she played
quickly so that is great that she didn't just burn
a lot of time on a move that only had one option
this is gonna be really really fun if we get
down to like you know two minutes i think it's
gonna become a really fun game do you like the the
fast chest better than five minutes absolutely you
live for the chaos i live for the chaos i do
also i just set my arm down and it like shook
and it made me very sad and i just like to
people should know that i think i i'm sorry for
for such a difficult situation it's been
hard for all of us yeah yeah exactly
well i feel bad if it's a pawn game and tubo is
just giving up his e6 pawn like this um in this
situation he could take the bishop and then still
go protect it but there's only one move that will
protect his pawn and i'm not sure he sees it it's
not the end of the world if he loses it of course
because code miko's pawn structure might get
a little bit shaky too with her pushing these
king side pawns but if he's the one to lose the
first spawn it might get in his head a little bit
yeah i'm curious it's interesting how slow
he's playing i can see a bishop trade here
yeah bishop trade would be totally okay honestly
even if he develops his knight that wouldn't be
too bad but i think we should take a listen
in on his stream because he's arrowing f4
did somebody give them a rule
to move just pawns for this game
that protects that porn oh yeah yeah that'll
protect that problem that would also get the check
he saw it and that is okay let me just
check it's not that it's protecting the
bishop so the bishop exchanged that could cut
me but uh yeah i'm going for it rap god tubber
i'm getting my queen up and out and then ideally
i want to get a rook there so i have two things
protecting that but then i would have no things
protecting that work until i move this horse
and this rook is currently completely
unprotected like that's a freebie
all right and code miko just moves her rook
away by moving a rook i think she's having
trouble finding the plan here yeah there was a
kind of cool line where she could have taken the
bishop pawn takes and then bring out her queen
to attack both of the two pawns it was very hard
to see though but the idea of trying to bring out
your queen that hasn't moved yet is important at
this stage in the middle game despite us always
coaching people to not take your queen out too
early i think they're both playing very passive
and like hoping that the other one does something
first you know like i so i'm curious to see how
this is going to end and when you were playing
pogchamps so so temple's almost down two minutes
now would that kind of situation stress you out or
how did you deal with it you know i'm gonna tell
you something about uh some advice i gave to mikko
is i said a lot of these low-level games
they end on time so just play fast is that
why she's been playing so quickly i i it could
be part of it because i a lot of the time is
you just play fast and you win on you win on the
clock and this could be one of those situations
and if it is i'm the best coach in pogchamps
if code miko pulls this game off cutie you are
goaded as the coach yeah we'll see he finally
moved his knight not towards the center because
it would have been taken on ds7 but he did develop
his night which is a great start it is just a
little bit awkward the knight on the rim is dim
and it doesn't have a ton of squares to hop into
unless he saw knight c2 which would protect his
bishop as well and get his knight into the game
miko doesn't know what to do i have a strong
feeling that she doesn't have a strong idea
for an attack right now i think she might push up
that c pawn uh just knowing her brain a little bit
she just when you don't know what to do when
in doubt play a pawn interesting yeah so well
remove her queen to get that out she moves her
queen that would be very good to see here i again
bishop takes d4 would be a great move because
the pawn takes and then she has the f6 square
for her queen but even if she doesn't combine the
two ideas and just move her queen up one square
that would be some really solid progress like you
said she is not going to let her clock past his
i know that there's no way she will do that
so she's going to move pretty soon here
i'm pretty confident another cutie pro tip i
i'm pretty confident that i told her yep clock
it's interesting how you guys have unique
perspectives from playing because there's
a lot of things that you know coaches who haven't
had the same experience are not going to totally
understand oh come on mikko let's go queen e7 yeah
i mean you've been playing this game your entire
life so you're going to have a
more refined understanding of it
and you would you would never say yo just went
on the clock you know what i'm saying like maybe
i'm gonna be like under the table and like just
went on the clock oh no she let the time pass
oh no oh i'm nervous for it just move that i don't
know i don't know what she's gonna do we'll see
uh okay well let's see what other i mean bishop
takes d4 if she is panicking she could also
just go for even trades that seems like an okay
strategy uh i'm nervous about how much time she's
taking now yeah and what is what is this what is
tubo doing it looks like he's phoning a friend
or something let's listen in on this uh talk
options yeah i didn't know oh no because that's
threatening the queen oh okay right okay i need
to focus now just have to take it that's it yeah
think about it see if i take that with my
rook that means that the other piece i'd have
to take with us the bishop and that would uh
yeah yeah i win a horse out of
this i want a horse out of this
calculator that's just a free horse they
come out underneath on this exchange
yeah yeah i want a horse from that that's not a
good move who knew i don't think so it might be
it might be something i'm just not even seen
yet it might have actually been a brilliant
move and i'm just a freaking idiot oh god i'm
stressing myself out jesus listen to me i'm crazy
it's it's wild how people always doubt themselves
and think that their opponent saw some kind of
brilliant move especially in these high pressure
tournaments yeah when niko or yeah mikko was
just going for it i think i love that he is
he was arrowing on oh oh my god rook takes
f8 and then if he takes with the queen or the
king she can gobble up one of those two pawns
he can gobble up one of those two pawns yeah um
he could probably even just take h5 straight up
if he wants to yeah that that's what i see him
doing he was arrowing on his board to bring
the rook from a1 over on f1 which i love stacked
i think that's a fun idea and he was really
excited about it so i think that might be in
the near future too as long as he protects his
queen first then yeah i hope to see the rook f1
but imagine he just skips it he's like screw it
i don't wanna yeah i just wanna he keeps arrowing
rook f1 but i i i think he's arrowing this for
the future okay yeah he took on h5 so he got the
free pawn i will say that goes just in panic right
now i i wish when miko panicked she would make
quiet moves like a6 instead of moves that are
super aggressive just because at least then if she
is panicking she won't drop as much material i'm
surprised she played the pawns that she pawns or
the the plays that she played i thought she would
do something more safe i think it's pure panic at
this point right and he does have a check made in
one threat let's see if she's going to try to get
out of it see that yeah she would have to take the
bishop which isn't a unusual move to do even if
she doesn't see the threat no yeah you're right
and and temple also arrowed queen g6 which
is another checkmate so he's seeing all of
his tactics here he's feeling pretty confident
right now nope he has made in one but it's on h8
let's take a listen on his stream see if he's
gonna see this checkmate that would be really
yeah they had to sacrifice their
castle for an exchange purely because
um it would have been a um it
would have been checkmate otherwise
okay right so uh that's no
longer checkmate if i had
to do that purely because that's a three square
why was that tricky
i don't know i have no clue but just seeing the
movement of bishops is stressful i don't know
definitely wider range so that might be partly
why okay so she moved she's playing fast now
there she is that's my girl yes no bias by the way
there is no bias i just i just love an underdog
you're a completely subjective commentator and
anyone who says differently is just being i also
like tubbo i just really would love mikko to
have one win right to have to have a win and
she hasn't had a win yet in the tournament
but that doesn't mean she didn't improve
i think she started at a lower level than
most people so hopefully people know that
and give her credit that she had to work
harder to get to where she is than it seems
oh interesting okay that's a great move she's
blocking the past pawn um what tubbo could do
is bring his horsey into the game or i mean of
course tactically he should take on g5 but if
he's trying to go for some kind of strategic
plan it's also good to activate the night
i think mika will just start playing with
those pawns over there moving forward i
know i've been saying that this whole time i
don't think i've called anything correctly but
well nick miko has been pushing her pawns
the entire time so i do agree with you on
that prediction and he hits her with the check
okay simplify if he wants you can also grab d5
totally up to him what he goes for here as
long as he doesn't blunder he's gonna be okay
and now he has queen d8 check as well
which is a really strong move because if the king
goes to the h file then he could bring his rook in
okay queen d6 he moved his queen from from threat
that's good oh finally a minute and 42 seconds oh
she's maybe see pawn that was protecting the wrong
pawn miko true but she does have 40 seconds and
tubbo has 50 so she is at least listening to
your playfast advice and he is playing faster
miko just play just play it's okay that's
your only chance right now is clock
true oh no there goes the rook the five
second increment is somewhat helpful but
i feel like psychologically once you're at 30
seconds no you're already stressed right yeah
yeah the increment is stressful yeah yeah yeah
and you don't remember when you started playing
quickly and you have more time you just feel
like you have five seconds the entire time
he didn't take her rook instead he protected
the pawn right and at least he's bringing
his knight closer into the kingside attack
so something like knight f5 oh i'm so sad
protected he's on clock right now come on be
gone six seconds oh she saved it she saved it
she saved her clock and her rook cutie
you should be proud oh come on mikko
oh she's she's she's hanging in there
she really she's gotten so much better
and if you don't give her credit for that
chat you're mean and i said it all right
calling them out there not everyone is amazing
at chess not everyone has been playing for years
oh just move just move the knight or not
oh okay so tumble can grab it king but and
he's bringing all of his pieces into the boat
yeah he is tumble's putting on the pressure
just run away mika run away i wonder if she has
any stalemate chances she would have to get rid of
her a7 pawn and then sacrifice her queen somehow
oh my gosh so greedy he's grabbing everything
just run with your king oh he's just oh
my god if there was no pawn it would have
been a stalemate if there was no pawn on a7 oh
wow yeah she actually got really close to cell
mating she should try a5 and and give away
her pawns and see if tubo takes them both
just like a little baby i don't think
she has any clue what to do right here
yeah yeah ah on the clock no and she's back at
3.95 but that's still much higher than where
she was last game so it was a good game she
she definitely improved and you can tell that
she also learned her pacing a little bit better
it was just a really tough middle game position
to handle right yeah and tubbo is celebrating
tubbo is happy about this well we'll be back with
the second match after a quick break so let's
see if code miko can come back on that chance
okay i'm gonna take the pond because if i
go they go yeah i don't want to trade queens
we're on chess tv oh my gosh highchest.com
thank you so much for coming here
to this sorry i'm so stressed
everyone on chess.tv is like we're scoping
out the competition i'm like i
don't even know what i'm doing
thank you to everyone from
chess.com who's coming to say hello
but i will never be hey he just
said pawn oh no how did this happen
shoot what did i do okay i'm
gonna have to go back through this
oh thank you so much for the gifted subs
oh i'm borked i think i'm bored i
think i'm done albert is too good
guys today i'm playing with subs if you'd
like to yes i can spot bam like bam and bam
is
this music also
good morning this is only the beginning
welcome back to pogchamps presented by grip6
we are about to see the second match between
tubo and codemigo their colors have reversed
now so we are going to be seeing code miko with
the white side of the pieces and tubo with the
black side of the pieces cutie was telling us
how much code mikko has been grinding and
she has improved she's still the underdog
but we're going to see if she can maybe push
a little fewer pawns this game so that she has
chances for a comeback what do you think she's
going to i know i don't know if she has an opening
actually i i i haven't taught her the stonewall
you didn't teach me we didn't get that far no
in our lesson we were talking about like the
way that the night moves and stuff like that so
i haven't taught i never taught her an opening i
think she had a lesson with anna i don't know how
far her and anna got um but so i'm not sure
if she has an opening memorized for white
and she can't just copy tubbo because she
moves first yeah so i don't know what she'll do
um anna would probably know oh so definitely not
the stonewall yeah well e4 is a good way to start
too i mean actually in her games that i've seen
so far her openings are actually pretty decent
once she gets out of them and i think
after her studying and it's always
random because of some kind of middle
game that's when she starts panicking
or on move to the things that i am confident she
knows is how to mate with king and queen because
we spent a good we spent a good while on it like
oh that's nice yeah how do you like coaching
by the way um i only like it on people that are
worse than me um i imagine you're not going to be
out here coaching hikaru well i scammed i scammed
pokeman into a lesson i i dm'd pokeyman and i said
hey you know i can squeeze you in for a lesson i
have to give hikaru a lesson on sunday and then
a god i made her a lesson on monday no
she just gave her number three oh no
this tub occurs wait is she trying to checkmate
him in four i mean it's obviously not going to
work now but was she going for the children yeah
she was she didn't see the horse she was just
focused on what she memorized well let's let's
listen on tumblr i'm just curious what he what
he has to say to this don't see a tempo oh he
arrowed it i think he saw it he's saying he's
the biggest chat am i nice oh it's so early on and
i don't want the second game to be over okay well
no okay no that's that's rude i don't mean i don't
mean it to be like over but i it's it's so early
i on to i can't throw three be ruthless oh
okay rambo and he takes it oh i feel so mean
i know i know mikko's mad right now she had that
memorized and was just zoned in on the on the line
and didn't actually the funny thing is um we
set up a practice match between myth and tubbo
and tubble was nice to myth but then mitch just
took his piece so maybe he learned his lesson
yeah i don't blame him i don't blame
him from that oh well i don't i don't
this is tough this is tough i i i feel i feel
bad because it felt like she had been training um
and i wish she would have had a better game than
this not to say that yeah she's still to try to
go for that fork on f7 with her knight right it's
never over it's never he has more of the gambits
memorized from the white side um and beautiful
castles he knows yeah he does she did learn the
bow gambit i didn't teach her that one i won't
take credit for that but wait i i i i know we
and my sister taught code miko but she did not
teach her the computer oh i didn't know andre i
did a lesson with her at this yeah yeah um but yes
i like giving lessons i thought pokemane would be
much worse but she was so good that my lesson with
her was feeble pokeman is actually really good i
think she has chances to oh i didn't see uh yeah
no she has chances to win the consolation bracket
okay bishop takes d4 so if you were code miko
and you're down a little tilted how would you
approach this game if it was your own pogchamps
game i would be tilted i would be so tilted
i think anything you do to recover oh
not that see there she's thinking wow i just
want to rook but didn't realize that it's equal
in peace and it's not actually a good move
because bishop takes b2 would win the rook
yeah but at least she's grabbing something maybe
if she would have there she is yeah she might as
well try she might as well try let's see if
she sees okay now she can attack the queen
and then push the bishop away she actually
if if she sees these two moves in a row and
develops really quickly she has some chances and
is that okay that's not okay all right well is
staring into her soul right now he is he is and
and you can tell that i mean he's playing good
chess and i i respect the fact that he took it
seriously regardless but i think he does feel bad
after the queen blender i will say tubbo needs
to remember to bring out the rest of his pieces
as well yeah he does leave those yeah very like oh
i've touched this i'm gonna keep doing that yeah
yeah amazing he can play so well with just half
of the board i know imagine if you used it right
that would be wild that'd be wild um and here he
is he pushes d6 fantastic move he's opening up
his bishop if he plays queen f3 and bishop h3 i'm
gonna be so proud of him and goes for the little
checkmate on g2 this is a a trick you can use
whenever the light squares are weak by the king
and you have a queen and a bishop okay we all
learned something people that nice nice nice um
okay cutie question for you if you were playing
hikaru you have the black pieces hikaru has the
white pieces in 10 seconds who wins dude carl
could be with his eyes closed and playing with
his feet hikaru could play with his feet with his
eyes closed he has 10 seconds i panic i don't even
move a piece i just get i have 20 minutes and i
still don't win there's no chance oh yeah that's
that's fair that's fair enough he beat me with
his eyes closed too so we're we're all in that
class he's a robot everybody with his eyes closed
you know i don't know what to do what's your robot
burn your robot brain the robot robot that's true
that's true um well code miko just gave away a
couple more pieces but again it's a tough position
and she's still putting up a fight which is good
queen h3 because imagine hubble miss clicks or
gives his queen for free you know that'd be very
exciting no i would love if that happened f4 just
because i want a more interesting game i think
tubbo is so confident right now admit it you hate
tubbo oh my gosh don't say that the minecrafters
will cancel me minecraft stands cutie cinderella
hates double extra extra get your news on
chess.com don't do it guys stop tubbo i'm a stan
i love minecraft what tell me some zoomer things
you're asking the wrong person
tommy in it isn't he am i in i think i think
you're safe now cutie one time carl tweeted at me
yeah i think you're safe i think you're
safe oh yes check okay now he can win the
night she can win that oh my gosh hello
coming back uh she has a passer now too
she has some chances and she's
good at pushing pawns cutie
yeah i do love i do love the pawn
when in doubt push a pawn i don't know
um okay so he can either take on f8 what else can
he try to do what else can she try to do i say he
because there's so many male players i've just
internalized it but what can code miko do here
press.com did hit their quota of two girls and
pog champs and yeah i will give them [ __ ] for it
until they have three girls because that's what we
need three girls at least three and then you know
what i'll do i'll say at least four i like it this
is your strategy each time you add one more until
there's 16 female participants yeah they put me on
the broadcast and then they're like oh gosh what
is she gonna do to get us canceled today well i
think they thought that by adding you and me to
commentary then we're good oh my gosh there are
four so really ends up i don't know how to count
oh there are four i was thinking mikko and
michelle i totally forgot about my queen pokeman
and nico good job chats.com yeah five next time
huh there you go there you go um all right well
well we we got it we got it now and they actually
have a ton of female commentators as well
so i i know they've been they've been putting
effort in on there so that's always nice to see
it's okay me my lack of counting is why i lost
pogchamps too so i know i mean if you would have
counted you would have beat dog dog changes the
game yeah exactly oh my gosh this is actually a
brilliant move because she is keeping the pieces
on the board she wants to do that when she's down
material so very impressive attempt from her here
what tubbo could go for is bishop f3 to threaten
checkmate on g2 and he sees it and now she has to
sacrifice but i still think it was a good try by
her if i hope she sees that she can also he can
also play rook f2 but then he'll take her bishop
so as long as as long as she protects
g2 somehow either by sacking or rook f2
and i will say if she does see the checkmate that
is very very impressive to keep fighting here
i mean i didn't even imagine she'd be able to
go this far after she lost her queen so early
yeah no she's she's recovered
pretty well i don't know
i i know she knows that something
is bad here um because sometimes i
feel like you get in this situation at
the end of your game where you're like
i know something's bad but i don't know how to
fix it and that's what just happened and tubbo
sees the check hubbo sees the check he goes 2-0
and truly tubbo did play these games very well
he didn't really miss a beat he gave code miko a
little bit of a chance here but then he cleaned it
up with getting his bishop on f3 that was a really
nice final tactic from him for sure and you guys
we will be right back with a post game interview
with code miko and tubbo so don't go anywhere
i think the best knife is the ruin dagger
probably just because the animation
which one the ruin daggers
from the battle pass see
ruined oh ruin and see what it looks like
i don't have it hatch this from the battle
pass last season i think that just like
flips around everywhere like when you right
click it like spins everywhere oh that one
wait what's wrong what's up oh wait
am i on the chest stream oh wait why
okay howdy ho yeah true we're just waiting
for my valor match to start um yeah
uh which map we go into now what was it i
got a joke chess people it's a chess joke
i liked our process when we got into the
agent screen it felt like everything was
clear we like knew what we were doing what are you
calling to talk about in lobby it was a mass man
a king and a queen living in a castle
what do you call it anybody know
it's a good one you might know it you
might know it if you're into the chess
yup yup you got it right good job
we are joined by tubo and code miko tubo just
played two fantastic games and code miko played
despite feeling sick today being one of the
newest to chess in the entire tournament so
even though she got eliminated she made a ton of
progress let's maybe start double congratulations
how do you feel these games went i i feel they
were i was thrown off a lot by a lot of the things
that you did and uh yeah it was still stressful
nonetheless the stress level has not changed
and code miko it looks like when you gave your
queen in the second game you're trying to go
to checkmate tubbo in four moves
is that what you were going for
um i was trying to um honestly i
don't know what i was not thinking
oh my gosh it's so bad
i was i was i thought honestly i thought
um okay this is gonna sound really
stupid but i thought my queen was my
bishop i love that well and i was trying
to get to the check you know the czech
thing that um that anna was like i forgot i was
like bishop to like some some on the board and
it's like diagonal to the king i was yeah you were
putting pressure on the the f7 pawn the one right
next to tubbo's yeah i think that's what you were
going for yeah well i i know cutie also gave you a
ton of advice like moving uh very fast and trying
to get under tubble's time and it seemed like you
were doing really well with time management in
the first game cutie you were really proud right
i was proud of you mikko you did good thank you
you know i think i think i was also excited to
see how much extra time you're putting in
chess even though i know it's infuriating
so seeing you just vibing the other day for
like hours playing chess yeah that was where you
got ill and um tubbo this the the sick twisted
mind of tubbo to take advantage of a sick girl
what do you have to say give it away oh i
feel i feel awful still it hasn't changed
oh well you are moving forward and you've made
so much crazy progress in chess over the last
month or so you're going
to be going up against nico
how do you feel your chances are
going to be again i no nico no no nico
um i have no idea what my chances
are gonna be i'll be honest
no worries are you gonna do anything to
prepare are you just gonna go in jamming
to the tunes and let your work until now show
itself yeah probably just the tunes the dancing
the instruments all of that
just just the normal stuff
i know that i liked your energy it was very
impressive thank you well tubbo congratulations
code miko thank you so much for being a part
of this tournament and making so much progress
in chess and for battling it through even when
you were feeling sick we really appreciate
having you here thanks for having me guys
this was really fun all right well bye bye
no last words i'm excited to see the next game
all right so let's talk a little bit about the
consolation bracket we have tubo the winner of
this match going up against nico tabo and nico
are very close in rating they're both in the 800
range so i think that is actually going to be a
very very close match and then we have pokemane
who beat myth yesterday and she's going to be
going up against the winner of mr beast and
michelle care who we just saw practicing chess
while we were on break and when we look
at the championship bracket there's a very
familiar face to cutie here cutie do you
want to talk about ludwig versus sardoche
listen i i have my calls and i'll say them
now pokey is winning the consolation bracket
and ludwig is winning the winner's bracket it's
time he has worked so hard and has missed so much
netflix time with myself by having late night
lessons with hess that if he doesn't win
i'm gonna be livid so well if there's any great
coach it's gonna be robert hess and ludwig i'm
sure is a fantastic student so it's just a dream
team over there and we're also going to have benji
fishy who's been training with a grand master
as well with grand master yoon ludwig hammer
who used to train magnus carlson and he's going to
be going up against rayne wilson who has just been
intimidating every single opponent so
far so the championship bracket is going
to be super sweet gary right benji i think
benji is taking over rayne benji has been
the scariest fortnight kid i've ever met
and you know we've met some scary ones and
i'm scarier than the minecraft kids you love so
much i i i love the minecraft look into the camera
and say it with the stream listen minecraft
kids use your twitch primes on on any channel
just use them i know there's a lot of you so you
know uh we love minecraft kids in yeah it's and
i don't know what to say anymore i'm so sorry
cutie yeah because she knows how i feel about
the minecraft kids no cutie you've been an
amazing co-host and it is so fun to have
you here in pogchamps 3 after you were there for
pogchamps 2. everybody watching i hope you had fun
and will tune in to the future games cutie any
final words you want to add before we let them
get off to the rest of their day and raid wgm
nemo who is going to be streaming no everyone
just make sure once we get to nemo's channel to
give her a smile and give her a follow and maybe
and maybe a prime minister maybe a prime all
right take care everyone goodbye let's go
get out take it
come out let's go
foreign
better
yes
oh